seven o'clock this is Sky News breakfast
these are our top stories this morning
clear the beds NHS bosses prepare for
major disruption during next week's
ambulance strike
day two of the latest rails strikes and
town and City centers up and down the
country are being hit on what should be
one of the busiest shopping days of the
year
as four people are killed in fresh
Russia missile strikes a senior
Ukrainian General Tel Sky News he's
preparing for the possibility of a huge
renewed Russian offensive
reports a U.S select committee is set to
move forward on pursuing criminal
charges against former president Donald
Trump
fun for some but snow and freezing
temperatures disrupt trouble for many
will bring you all the latest
and also have the sport for you as
England's cricketers take on Pakistan in
a third test in Karachi
is
in a program of festive trees from
Grammy award-winning singer Josh Stone
who's releasing her first Christmas
album
and as a quarter two we'll take a look
at the papers with peach price and Gemma
Forte
foreign
good morning welcome to the program
hospitals are being worn to free up the
maximum number of beds ready for
extensive disruption when ambulance
Crews walk out next week
and it shows England's Chief Operating
Officer sir David sloman is suggesting a
raft of other measures to get through
what he says will be a very challenging
period
well ambulance crews are due to walk out
for two days on December the 21st and
the 28th in support of their pay claim
in a letter to hospitals he calls for
patients who are complete emergency
medical care to be moved out of
emergency departments and the rapid
discharge of medically fit patients from
acute Community and Mental Health wards
the aim is to free up beds this may
involve the creation of observation
areas and additional beds elsewhere in
the hospital
s are also being urged to put in place
plans to release all ambulances from
emergency departments within 15 minutes
and get them back on the road
currently some hospitals have queues of
ambulances waiting for hours to
discharge patients
well our political correspondent Rob
Powell joins me now from Westminster and
Rob anisha's boss is there warning of
some big trouble ahead yeah I think you
get a sense that bosses in the Health
Service and also government ministers
seem arguably more worried about this
ambulance worker strike that's due on
Wednesday than they are about the nurses
strike that is due on Tuesday the first
day of which happened
um on Thursday on Thursday last week as
well I I think what the aim of this
letter that went out to hospitals last
night from NHS leaders is is to try and
free up beds in hospitals to get rid of
the bottleneck that means that patients
can't be moved from a e from emergency
Wards onto normal Wards and as a result
that bottleneck means that ambulances
can't drop off new patients and are
facing long waits to hand over patients
to hospital staff now if that happened
on a strike day it may mean that the
ambulances that are on the road that
aren't impacted by the strike action
could be sniled up outside hospitals
making the whole situation worse so
that's why you're seeing this attempt to
safely discharge any patients where it's
possible now this dispute is separate
from the nursing dispute it's it
involves England and Wales ambulance
workers paramedics other 999 staff who
are represented by three big unions GMB
unite and Unison it's about pay though
so the issue is the same as the nurse's
dispute the unions want something that
goes somewhere near inflation or keeps
up with Rising prices so you're talking
double digits the government offers so
far is between four and five percent and
last night the business secretary Grant
chaps suggested the government would not
look again at this issue of pay this is
what he said
the government has done its part by
saying okay it's tough times we know
that but we're going to accept it uh
remember if Moore is paid to one group
then there's less available for others
so this affects everybody in the public
services and a responsible government
has got to make this Stack Up
now there have been some Provisions made
to try and offset some of the disruption
we know about troops going into
hospitals to train up to help with
ambulance Crews now they won't
necessarily be driving ambulances on
emergency call-outs but they'll be
dealing with other more routine issues
of course this comes as nurses prepare
to walk out again one day before
ambulance workers ambulance workers walk
out you'll get nurses going on strike as
well their first day of strike action on
Thursday saw 16
000
surgeries appointments procedures
reschedule now that is far below what
was estimated by the government
initially they had estimated seventy
thousand so not as much disruption
caused as they had previously expected
there doesn't seem any resolution on
that row on the horizon either though
Pat Cullen the General Secretary of the
Royal College of Nursing has given an
interview to the times today accusing
the health Secretary of adopting a macho
and confrontational approach to talks
now she wants the Prime Minister Rishi
soon act to step in he's already made
clear though that he thinks the existing
pay settlement should be kept to
Robin Westminster thank you
towns and citizens will be hit today on
what should be one of the busiest
shopping days of the year it's day two
of the latest strike by Rel staff and
it's having sorry a devastating impact
on shopkeepers and bar owners we'll also
fresh talks with the government the rmt
leader McLean says he believes a deal is
achievable but for now very little is
moving
apologies for that
what this latest 48-hour strike is
affecting Network realm and 14 operating
companies Nationwide
just
just a fraction of scheduled trains will
be running to give you a sense of the
disruption only one in five trains
running the most recent strike and as a
result some services will start later
and finish earlier with some areas going
through any trained Services whatsoever
and then disruption is expected to
continue into tomorrow as some trains
will not be in their usual starting
positions on regular days well let's
bring in Emma virtually now who's at
London Paddington Station for us this
morning and Emma day two of the strikes
and still no end in sight when it comes
to the standoff between unions and the
government
yes and a what a difficult time for it
to come for people trying to get out
shopping this is the penultimate
Saturday before Christmas I've been in
and had a look at the departure boards
inside Paddington Station nothing
running until half past seven and then
only a handful of trains up and down the
country
um every hour and the same up and down
the country so
um this will cause an enormous amount of
disruption and of course shops really
need the business
um after what's been an incredibly
difficult time with the covid pandemic
there have been predictions about how
the hospitality industry is going to be
hit during December as they say it's
going to cost 1.5 billion pounds so
people canceling Christmas dues bars
restaurants all being hit an incredibly
difficult time now and when you listen
to what Mick Lynch the General Secretary
of the rmt has to say he he said most
recent that very simple steps are needed
on both sides he believes to reach some
kind of solution so maybe it's possible
that the strikes due to begin on
Christmas Eve once more could be called
off but that is going to require some
kind of breakthrough and this week
already we have seen four days of
strikes and if things aren't resolved
again into the new year the disruption
continues another four days two 48-hour
strikes planned for that first week in
January so an incredibly difficult time
for people an incredible amount of
uncertainty
and not knowing quite simply whether
they can get a train when they want one
Emma thank you
or two Ukraine now where at least four
people have died and what's been
described as a massive new wave of
Russian missile strikes in the past 36
hours
the attacks came as a senior Ukrainian
Commander warned that he's preparing for
the possibility of a huge renewed
Russian offensive involving hundreds of
thousands of troops who have more on
that in just a moment but first let's
take a look then at the latest attacks
which have again targeted infrastructure
there were powerful explosions in a
capital cave Northeastern hakif and also
in president zielinski's hometown of
crevary
the Black Sea region of Odessa was also
hit including the Central City of
Venezia poltava and Northern Sumi region
ukrainians sale for 76 missiles fired 60
were shot down
in Kiev residents had to take shelter
inside and around train stations
elsewhere many areas across the country
were left without power
is our security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes on the warning of plans
for a significant Russian offensive in
the new year
this is one of Ukraine's top commanders
Andre Kovalchuk led a major offensive
that we captured the southern city of
her son
he's now focusing on new targets but
also preparing for a possible fight back
by Russia one year on from The
full-scale Invasion people think maybe
on the anniversary the 24th of February
Russia will try again to attack from the
north from the east from the south are
you anticipating that could happen
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
the general said Russia's Vladimir Putin
May ultimately order millions of his
soldiers to fight
[Music]
and would he be able to deal with that
[Music]
um
Army
this was the commander as he toured her
son city after its liberation last month
he says Ukraine will win this war it's
just a matter of when
is
as a decorated and highly experienced
officer he knows that could well mean
the fiercest fighting is yet to come
Deborah Haynes Sky News in southern
Ukraine
obviously some of today's other
headlines now and a man and woman have
been arrested following the discovery of
the bodies of two young boys as an
address in East London Emergency
Services were called to the address in
dagenham where they found the bodies of
two boys age two and five who died at
the scene Metropolitan Police says both
adults were known to the children
three women aged 21 23 and 33 remain in
a critical condition in hospital
following a crush outside a concert by
the afrobeat artist ashake in Brixton in
South London
police were called to The Venue after
Witnesses reported that some members of
the crowd had tried to force their way
into the venue
the government has launched an 18
million pound information campaign to
help people save energy and cut their
bills
the campaign will provide trips on tips
on some simple steps to take like
turning appliances off at the plug and
insulating your home properly using
drought excluders
it's to help families save money off
their own energy bills with actually
some surprisingly straightforward
measures some of which people may not
have heard of before like turning down
the boiler flow temperature which
doesn't impact on the temperature of
your house or the radiators but can save
you perhaps 100 pounds a year on average
a charges against former U.S president
Donald Trump in connection with the 2021
Capital riots have moved a step closer
the U.S House select committee
investigating the attack is preparing to
vote on urging the justice department to
pursue criminal charges against Mr Trump
charges which could include Insurrection
and conspiracy Skies James Matthews has
the latest
these charges would come as no real
surprise this January the sixth
committee has spent many months laying
down an Insurrection timeline with
Donald Trump very much at its heart for
them to conclude that there should be no
criminal charges would be for them to
say he has no questions to answer and
that is extremely unlikely to happen
it's not a decision for this Committee
of course to launch a prosecution this
is a politician's decision they make the
referral to the Department of Justice
and it's for them to decide whether or
not to pursue criminal charges they will
say this is an airtight investigation
very much for them not affected by
external events but it does change the
context in which they operate for the
political detectives to recommend the
prosecution it makes it awkward for the
actual detectives to then turn round and
say Donald Trump doesn't have a case to
answer that would not necessarily be
straightforward in the middle of all of
this of course is Donald Trump himself
planning a run for a second term in the
white house but now staring down the
barrel of more time spent in the
courthouse than on the campaign Trail
James Matthews then the UK is still in
the grip of the cold weather with yellow
weather warnings issued for today and
tomorrow our correspondent Katarina
vitotsi has spoken to one family about
how the Sub-Zero temperatures are
worsening the impacts of the rising
costs of living for them
it's 6 p.m and already minus three James
the Williams family know they bought
another cold night ahead so how has it
felt in here over the last couple of
nights
absolutely freezing
um
I knew I constantly sat watching that
meter
how does that make me feel
sick because it's usually over budget by
the end of every week
the Collision of freezing temperatures
and the rising cost of living has hit
this family with unbelievable Force
Claire works full time but even when
it's so cold can barely afford to put
the heating on
we'll put it on for about 15-20 minutes
maybe when we get home from work and
school
and then it's off again for the rest of
the night and it doesn't go on in the
morning
can't afford to
must be hard to the kids ever say mom
can we just put the heating on for
another 10 minutes another five minutes
yeah I mean the first thing that they
want to do when they come home from
school is put the heating on because
they're usually home before me
but bless them they wait until I get
home
because they know it's expensive
so they'll just snuggle themselves up in
blankets
there is no respite though from the cold
and it's making them all sick
intensifying 14 year old Benjamin's
asthma
it's been absolutely freeze I want to go
to bed
and
I've not been able to sleep properly
because it's just affected the way that
I can breathe I come back in and it's
freezing I can't feel my hands
[Music]
um
so I just got into this and wrap up on
the sofa that must be pretty hard to
hear it is I mean I in a pretty decent
wage
um
I should be able to provide a warmer
home for my kids but we're having to
kind of ration I don't claim any
additional benefits or anything like
that
um so people like us get left
left to a winter with many cold months
ahead
gosh it does feel colder up here
or sort of a toll is it taking on you
I'm tired
um and when it comes to the point you're
considering whether I need to get a
second job or not
will I be able to do that
their festive lights are up but not on
theirs is a season not of abundance but
of economies where the Wish isn't for a
white Christmas just a warm one
Catherine evertotsi Sky News in Cheshire
and joining me now is Sky meteorologist
Kirsten McCabe and Kirsty at least one
more night of freezing temperatures to
contend with
that's right Vanessa it has been another
very cold night for many of us although
for some parts of Scotland Ireland and
the Northwest actually temperatures here
are higher than they've been on previous
nights but still for many it's Sub-Zero
this morning so widely across the UK and
Ireland you can see it's a very cold
start today in some parts of the UK
especially towards the northeast of
Scotland and also across central
Southern England we've seen temperatures
-6 to -10 minus 12.2 in rittle which is
near Chelmsford in Essex so that's the
coldest spot so far this morning we have
got weather warnings out as you'd expect
it's a yellow weather warnings for ice
mainly across parts of Scotland also
Western fringes of England and Wales and
that's where we've had the snow in
previous days is causing icy conditions
this morning but also we've got some
wintry showers coming in today so some
bands of rain sleet and snow moving in
from the west from the Northwest and
they'll be sinking a little bit further
south but mainly affecting Western
Scotland western parts of Wales the
south west of England Northern England
so it was the main focus for some wintry
showers today again a bitterly cold day
maybe a degree or two higher than
previous days but changes coming with
the jet stream that's going to be moving
northwards again so by the time it gets
to us it will bring some very wet and
windy conditions but also much milder
air by Monday temperatures jumping up
into double digits difficult transition
though Sunday when the rain comes in
we're going to see a brief period of
snow a risk of freezing rain so a risk
of black ice on the roads and still very
cold across the far north could be some
blizzard conditions for a time with this
very wet and windy weather coming in and
then Monday look at the difference in
the temperatures 13 14 degrees it's
going to feel positively welcome change
I'd say the usual December average is
around say 68 degrees so very much
milder by the time we get to Monday now
if you're wondering if we'll hold on to
the mild weather well the run-up to
Christmas looks like things might turn a
little bit colder again but not as cold
as what we've just had
now in the 20 years since cancer
research UK was founded death rates from
the disease have fallen by 16 due to
improvements in screening and more
effective treatments well I'm now joined
by jayashree Jal who as you can see is
in the screen who's been cancer-free for
10 years and she was diagnosed with
breast cancer in 2006.
um oh I'm so sorry jayshree
you're diagnosed in 2006
um and also
um we have as you can see here
um Jackie of course our very own Jackie
Bell Trail who's also a cancer survivor
and jayashree I'll come to you first
thank you firstly so much for taking the
time out to speak to us and I'll come to
you first I just want to get an
understanding and I know that it will be
very difficult but what can you remember
that moment when the news was delivered
to you what was going through your mind
at the time
when I've been told you have a cancer I
thought I got death sentence I was numb
but then I decide no I'm going to fight
I'm not going to sit corner of the sofa
and feel sorry for myself
absolutely and and Jackie I mean what
Jay SRI saying is that something that
you Echo as well what was it like
because of course for you it was 2013
when you were diagnosed and then you had
another blow in 2020 so what was it like
for you when that news was delivered
well 2013 I got diagnosed on Christmas
Eve and it was just the worst worst
Christmas ever because like Jay shree I
thought death sentence I'm going to die
you know the worst moment of my life
but then when I was re-diagnosed and I
actually got through that and did the
chemo and took the nasty medicine all
the rest of it when I got through that
and then I was diagnosed you know later
on in 2020 with stage four cancer which
is not curable you just hope it can be
managed for as long as it can be managed
I would have given anything to swap that
moment for the original moment that I
thought was so bad back in 2013
realizing that you know it's it's so
curable for many women now my situation
is very unusual and most people are like
Jay shree and they will have their bouts
with with breast cancer and and they
will they'll move on from it not not
everyone of course but you know cancer
research has has come so far in such a
short time and Jay Street how have
things been for you in terms of the
sorts of treatments that you've been
having and just living in just kind of
going through the initial stages
um when the announcement was obviously
first broken
yeah what happened I was working with
Luke and PCD and my subject was breast
cancer awareness of the breast cancer
and smoothness and they give me project
where I got the world to this and then
everywhere and so the ladies you know
how to check your breasts and things
like that and when I was 69 it was my
last appointment for the mammogram
I went there
and find out about the tumor and I think
mammograms saved my life they find they
treat because it was the last but those
days after 70 they don't send the
appointment but now we can do the
appointment after 70 but we have to make
it we automatically don't come
and my my message is all the legislation
ladies all my friends and family I asked
them will you go for mammogram if you oh
no with 70 we can't go I says yes you
can go you can make the appointment and
check early you find out early chances
you have recovering for yourself
um and this I'm doing even now yeah no
absolutely and actually Jackie what J
Street is saying there and one of the
things that I also get from you is that
message of empowering people to actually
you know face his head on but also get
getting yourself checked as well yeah
and Jay Street you know well done for
insisting on that mammogram because
there there is a problem
um you know the NHS have acknowledged
there is a problem with the South Asian
community and the black community not
turning up to their screenings there's
also a cultural thing of the mother is
in charge of the family and and has to
be strong and you know it kind of puts
themselves at the bottom of the pile if
they need to go
to the doctor or they have a problem or
they find a lump and and really that you
know that that shouldn't be the case and
just you know Well Done J sharifa you
know you're sticking to your guns and
and going there because a lot of women
might might not have done that and it's
really crucial isn't it because it's
about catching it early isn't it and
what can be done rather than waiting for
the situation to get to a stage four for
example whereas you say you cannot cure
it you can't try and manage it well yes
I mean getting it early obviously is is
very key in J Street you know fantastic
that you're you look so healthy and so
well I mean not everybody can see see
the lump not everybody can you know can
be that lucky that you know you've
you've spotted something and it's early
it might be something that doesn't
manifest itself as a lump which is why
you know going to screenings is is so
good but what's amazing about our
situation is that in the last 10 years
research has come so far that you're you
know you're very targeted now in terms
of your treatment it's not like everyone
has given loads of chemo it's very
specific to your cancer did you have
chemotherapy jayshree
yes I have I've been told by the
consultant I don't need chemo and Edison
because my cancer was fed too yeah and
they removed they says they can remove
the nipple and take the tumor out and
that's it but I was volunteered to do
the proper surgery
and I said um I I would like to have a
chemo as well but the consultant says
why you have to go because you don't
need it but I volunteer and I had my
sixth cycle of chemo until
I I just want to just um find out from
you where is it that you draw your
strength from and how when you were
going through that what kept you going
is it your family for example that kept
you going
yeah my family's support is fantastic my
daughter was in Canada she came from
Canada my daughter-in-law my husband my
son or the pillar of my life they helped
me a lot
and they encouraged me and
um that time I was working with NHS and
my title was Community food advisor
and after the chemo I started my working
I lost all my hair so I was wearing cap
and scarf and people says why are you
wearing a scarf so I take it out and I
have to cancel I don't hide my illness I
tell everyone early you find out early
you have a chance to survive
okay so just go for the mammogram check
if you find anything mammogram or any
cancer
at least stage you have more survive and
if you have the cancer this this is more
and more and save people's lives and I
believe in that hundred percent thank
you so much Jason and Jackie I have to
come to you because I see you here every
day you well most things are when we're
here and you just come in and you just
crack on with it and I also want to ask
you the same question where do you get
your strength from what is it that keeps
you going it's the drugs mostly
in the nicest possible way you know I've
been very lucky in my unluckiness you
know you could say because I've got a
stage four cancer it's technically not
curable but I'm on the very very latest
drug that's come off the the research
line and for me it's worth like
spectacularly well to the point where
you know one of my scans I was riddled
with cancer three months later there was
nothing there to see and that you know
that drug would not have been available
I don't know five years ago it just it
just wouldn't have existed for my type
of cancer so I just I just feel very
very lucky that people are constantly
beavering away trying to find that cure
and it will come it's just it just take
a little bit of time but it but it will
come but but we're seeing it and it's
just fantastic and it's fantastic to
just as I say just seeing you just going
on just cracking on with it is what I
was just saying it to you you just crack
on with it what else are you gonna do I
know right exactly no it's fantastic and
Jay shree has been so lovely speaking to
you thank you so much for taking that
time out to speak to us but also just
reiterating that advice go and get
yourself checked so Jay srijal and also
our very own Jackie thank you very much
indeed to both of you for speaking to us
thank you
now Sam writer said it looks like
Christmas came early after his debut
album topped the UK charts
[Applause]
[Applause]
his album there's nothing but space man
reaching number one in the charts means
that he's become the first precious male
solar artist to reach number one in more
than three years the 33 year old singer
has finally clinched top spot after
finishing second in a Eurovision song
contest and seeing his Eurovision entry
Spaceman peek at number two in the
singles chart two
I just want to put it out there he's got
a good head of hair doesn't he let's see
how the weather is looking
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the weather system in the Atlantic
will bring some Far milder conditions by
the end of the week but there is always
a but change will be very messy
currently we're still in the cold air
with some showers over many northern and
western parts this is given way to some
Icy stretches on a number of Roads
meanwhile in the South and the southeast
as it's largely clear and bitterly cold
with some fog patches
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up after the break I'll be joined
by broadcaster Pete price and
broadcaster and writer Gemma Fortier for
a look at some of today's Insight pages
[Music]
I'll go back with us this morning to
review the papers are broadcaster and
writer Gemma Fortier and broadcaster
Pete price and like magic Fabia right
now it's good to have both of you and
Pete I do note the change in t-shirt
there
let me um just come to you first um
Gemma this is an interesting story here
so the headline that we're seeing
Parliament sex stories accused of sleaze
on official trips overseas so a lot of
people will be wondering what is this
all about
um in the times page six just tell us a
little bit more about what this is about
I'll let you explain here
okay so it is indeed a sleazy little
story here so it's all about all party
parliamentary groups now these are
informal parliamentary bodies they are
sort of cross-party and what happens is
peers or MPS who have a cause that they
feel really passionate about they will
liaise with other countries and they
will go off essentially on all paid all
expenses paid trips on their own you
know on work time to go and promote
these issues or indeed to sort things
out and they do obviously have working
itineraries while while they're there
but apparently they're also using and
abusing these trips to indulge in some
rather borish old-fashioned gross
Behavior quite frankly like it isn't on
to be representing your country than to
be asking oh where's the nearest brothel
which has been reported
um so Chris Bryant who heads up
parliamentary select committees he is
saying look these are serious Grievances
and they should be reported and we
should be looking into them and
obviously this isn't acceptable but also
really really uncomfortable for any
women who are involved on these trips
and they sort of talk about very
entitled Behavior very arrogant you know
perhaps not speaking to people in the
correct way as well and just not
conducting themselves in a proper way
and not being discreet about this
Behavior at all so not very pleasant and
very very awful in the times that we're
living in as well to be abusing these
expenses and going off on these jollies
and then behaving like that and of
course within this article no individual
named or implied of course and there are
also some recommendations and committees
reports and recommendations did not
concern the behavior of MPS on trips is
what was what it says here in terms of
what changes there could be let me move
on then to the next story
um Pete I'll come to you for this one
this is in the um page seven of the eye
and it's an interesting one so the
government's starting some energy saving
advertising costing a few Millions but
two things here this is something that a
lot of people were calling for
um at the start of
um the awesome period but also the
advice some of them it's a little bit
Common Sense isn't it switching off the
power from the plugs I mean you think
I shake my head in disbelief with this
article uh can I remind everybody I'm
not a lover of Boris but when Boris said
put a blanket around your legs watching
television everyone laughed at him and
mocked him I've got a blanket over there
now which I use watching television I
think it's really nice they're simple
ideas I come from a lifetime where I was
taught to put the lights off in every
room as I went out and that's what I do
now in fact I've got too many lights on
here this is actually costing me money
today but it's sensible Sensible things
but let me please bar humbug where I
live I've never seen so many Christmas
decorations outside houses I thought
people had no money I don't know what's
going on it is sensible turn your
heating down and switch a radio for a
radiator off in a room that you're not
using and here's a little tip buy a slow
cooker put in a paliscal House cost
nothing and you can't go throw
everything in stock you and there's some
nice food to eat as well it's been
common it's listen older people could
could write this advert well Pete I
should probably move to where you are
because of my streets nobody is putting
up any Christmas decorations I don't
know what's wrong with them
I'm not gonna do it
when I live you you just you don't need
street lights you honestly don't need
Street like that they've gone deaf
um Gemma let me um come to you then this
next story is interesting I mean I I
just had a little Chuckles myself just
reading reading it the telegraph's paid
for bring your family to work to sort
the festive posts
you must have some very kind family
members who agree to do that
flat out at this time of year but yeah
this is Royal Mail
A desperate bid but of course they are
trying to enable the post to be arriving
in the midst of strike action I mean is
it easier at this point to list public
sector workers that aren't going to be
striking across the board and I really
hope the government start to listen and
look at the sort of barometer of how
workers are feeling across the board so
yes staff being asked just like enlist
help anybody you can get your hands on
granny brother daughter who can come in
and they will apparently be paid agency
uh fees um which this is another thing
it's such a sort of false economy in the
end not paying people properly it's a
bit like in the NHS there were those
reports of wildly expensive agency
doctors coming in for sort of five
thousand pounds a day so yeah it's all a
bit of a mess isn't it but yes don't be
expecting cards to be turning up on time
at this rate well I've got two nephews I
may have to make the most of them then
and not pay them I wouldn't get away
with it I tell you that one um and Pete
this story is very interesting because
weirdly enough one of my weird fears has
been seeing some of these aquariums and
thinking what if it bursts like the one
behind you for example
so there's 82 foot aquarium tsunami as
they're saying in Berlin that's just
just remarkable
yeah sadly uh 1 500 fish are dead uh a
million liters of water and it broke uh
they reckon it's because of the cold
weather so it wasn't uh anything
Sinister uh because it was the cold
weather but it's in a hotel luckily it
broke when it broke and there weren't
many guests around a couple of guests
have been
um had a problem with splinters of glass
but imagine if when people were checking
out this went and burst but that's my
fear as well and I come from an age once
again in the old days
just run out of time we've just ran out
of time don't go too far don't go too
far we'll be back after this break
foreign